on en parle avec françois guérin
historien spécialiste en géostratégie et
président fondateur de l'institut
français d'analysé stratégique
bonjour monsieur merson jour accepté
notre invitation alors c'est le premier
déplacement d'un chef d'état à l'école
de guerre depuis de gaulle est ce que le
le discours de emmanuel macron revêt
cette année un caractère particulier
traditionnellement les présidents de la
république ont pris l'habitude de faire
un grand discours pour cadrer la
stratégie française
ça a été le cas à deux reprises par le
président chirac
et puis ensuite nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande donc macron s'inscrit dans une
tradition ça faisait cinq ans qu'il n'y
avait pas eu deux du secours portant
spécifiquement sur les armes nucléaires
france
donc d'un côté il fait un rappel de ce
qu'est la position traditionnelle de la
france
il dresse un bilan plutôt alarmistes de
du contexte géostratégique
internationale en constatant en
particulier qui a un phénomène de
dérèglements un phénomène de course aux
armements et il en appelle donc à un
retour à une espèce d'ordre à une espèce
de contrôle
justement de la situation de manière à
se retrouver dans un monde complètement
chaotique
justement vous parlez de l'armé
nucléaire on sait que la france
aujourd'hui le seul pays de l'union
européenne depuis la sortie du royaume
uni
évidemment de l'union de d'être en
possession de l'armé nucléaire est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la france a vocation à
être protecteur justement on peut
induire théoriquement oui
la question c'est de savoir si il y à
véritablement de la part des pays
européens membres de l'union une demande
par rapport à une protection française
et là on est incontestablement devant
une sorte traditionnellement d'impasse à
chaque fois que la france a fait des
propositions dans ce sens on lui a dit
poliment non mairie
non merci on verra plus tard des pays
comme l'allemagne des pays comme la
pologne regarde avant tout l'otan comme
l'élément fondamental de leur protection
à la fois avec les armements
conventionnels mais aussi avec les
armements nucléaires des états unis donc
il faudrait que se dégage une unité
stratégique de vue entre lire c'est
l'ensemble des membres de l'union
européenne pour dire oui nous voulons
une défense européenne
nous avons les mêmes préoccupations
stratégiques
or ce n'est pas de cadre ou aujourd'hui
et oui nous voulons avoir les mêmes
instruments que la france pourra fournir
maintenant restera la question
fondamentale en matière de stratégie
nucléaire qui a le pouvoir ultime de
décision on ne peut pas être 26 avec un
doigt sur le bouton
il faut enfin de compte qu' une seule
personne dans l'otan c'est exactement la
même chose
c'est le chef suprême des armées est
toujours un général américain qui a in
fine et l'autorité sur les armes
nucléaires directement en relation avec
le président des états unis
donc c'est une chaîne de commandement
extrêmement étroites extrêmement
pyramidale et dans le cas de l'union
européenne ça se poserait dans les mêmes
termes
est ce que c'est le président français
il serait garant de la protection
nucléaire de l'ensemble des états
membres
et là on n'est pas encore mûr pour
affronter ce problème alors parmi aussi
les thèmes qui ont été abordés hier la
russie puisque emmanuel macron a une
nouvelle fois prôné un rapprochement
avec moscou
il faut retrouver des liens de confiance
la russie doit être partenaire de la
sécurité collective est ce que vous
pensez que d'autres pays vont suivre la
france non cet appel oui certainement
ces deux faits la position de
l'allemagne est incontestablement
mais ce n'est pas la position de
l'ensemble des membres de l'union
européenne ni de l'ensemble des membres
de l'otan il y avoue le cv un certain
nombre de pays qui considèrent la menace
en europe reste la russie et donc qu'il
faudrait sortir de ce schéma de
confrontation ce qui suppose
naturellement d'avoir un dialogue
stratégique avec la russie qui est
aujourd'hui absolument indispensable on
ne peut pas penser la sécurité
européenne
en dehors de ce dialogue avec la russie
faut donc et donc emmanuel macron a
soutenu la proposition de l'as dit merde
poutine d'une réunion des cinq membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies pour avoir un regard sur
les difficultés qui se présentent
aujourd'hui et la manière de les
résoudre
donc il ya une convergence de vues sur
une volonté de dialogue faut que ce
dialogue s'engage et qui s'engage
évidemment avec un minimum de bonne
volonté et des démonstrations de retour
à disons un certain calme et un certain
ordre en matière de développement des
armements
on ne peut pas avoir un dialogue de
sécurité et continuer à augmenter les
stocks d'armes est allé modernise très
bien en tout cas merci beaucoup monsieur
françois guerre et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et président fondateur de
l'institut français des analyses
stratégiques persie